Well, everybody welcome to Drew's News,
your all you can eat news buffet,
full of fresh, good-news-itarian options.
(Ross giggles)
And with me at the desk,
a true buffet connoisseur, Ross Mathews.
(audience cheers)
Well, now that's true.
I do love a buffet.
Hi everybody.
Why a buffet?
(audience applauds)
I love a buffet.
What's your number one buffet tip, Ross?
Well, I like that you can go all the way around the world.
You can have egg roll and spaghetti all in one place.
Thank you, buffets, I have missed you.
I will make you fall in love with buffets, Drew.
I promise I'm the man to do it.
I got the elastic pants, I'm ready to go.
All right, let's dig into our extra special edition of
Food News!
Yeah.
(audience applauds)
First up, we're talking about the next frontier in food.
There's a food innovation that you can try out, right now,
just across the river in Jersey City.
Fox Business reports that the Newport Center Mall
has just installed a hamburger vending machine.
Oh, gosh. (chuckles)
It's called RoboBurger,
and it cooks up fresh burgers, made to order
in just six minutes.
The robot grills your patty,
toasts your bun
and then squirts your burger with some condiments.
Ross?
Yes.
Thoughts.
Well, you know, there are inventions
where you always remember where you were
the first time you heard about them.
This is one of those inventions.
RoboBurger, welcome to the family.
And I say this as somebody who worked at McDonald's,
I talk about it proudly here,
I know how to assemble a hamburger.
Triple threat.
Triple threat, register,
drive-through and grill.
(audience member cheers)
Thank you very much.
(audience laughs)
And so I'm watching that.
Were you guys watching that robo do its thing, on there?
I like your technique, robo.
You know how to make a burger.
I would eat one of these.
So imagine this, it's frozen patties in there.
They're grilling them to your specifications,
how you want it.
Would you try a RoboBurger?
I would.
I like burgers occasionally,
and I like veggie burgers,
so I hope they have both options
'cause I'm a super flexitarian.
Yeah. What's next?
You think there's gonna be a RoboTaco?
I mean, possibly-
Oh my God!
Why? I mean, it's endless.
Wait a minute.
Why can't we have RoboBaked Potato Bar?
(audience laughs)
Thank...
You're a genius, Drew Barrymore.
You remember the Jetsons?
And we were always like,
"When are we gonna live in that time?"
Well, welcome to the future, everybody.
That's right, that's right, Rossy.
All right, well now we've got a unique dining experience
that could be coming to a city near you,
other than RoboBurger.
Good News Network reports,
you can now get a gourmet meal cooked over hot molten lava.
Wha?
Now, if you like hibachi but wish it was just more extreme,
than this meal is for you.
It was created by Bompas and Parr,
an innovative food group out of London.
And they hosted the first lava dinner
in an ancient canyon, in Saudi Arabia.
Wow.
They know how to do it.
Fancy.
Uh-huh.
Guests ate steaks and fish charred over fresh hot lava.
Where do you even get lava?
I don't know, but you know the degree that lava is?
It's 2,462 degrees Fahrenheit.
(audience gasp)
That's hot.
And you know what they had for dessert?
Chocolate lava cake, hello.
I mean, perfect.
(audience applauds)
Perfect.
Has anyone here ever deep fried a turkey?
Raise your hand if you have.
(Ross laughs)
This woman, over here, you did, right?
Wait, where?
In the pink shirt.
Right here, right here, in the front corner.
Oh my gosh.
May I ask what your name is?
Lori.
How did it go when you deep fried a turkey?
Well, my ex-husband did it,
but it was really good.
I always wanted to attempt the fried turkey
and the hot oil
Oh yeah.
But all I ever heard was how, you know,
people can lose finger.
I mean, it's so dangerous.
Uh-huh.
Yes.
And I'm scared.
And yet I really wanna try it,
'cause God, I'll eat a shoe that's been deep fried.
For sure.
(Lori laughs)
What about next year?
But I'm scared.
And this gives me the lava.
I need a panic attack medicine.
Yeah.
Who's slinging lava
around the deep fried turkeys?
This takes it way too far.
Would you try it, the lava?
No, I never even tried the deep fried turkey
'cause I'm too scared.
Oh, I would totally try the lava
and I just have to say, next Thanksgiving,
we should get a deep fryer and a Turkey,
'cause I'll get in it, gobble-gobble.
I'll get in there, Drew, let's do it.
What do you think, should I try it?
Yes.
Yes!
Maybe you'll come back for,
where do you live?
Boston.
That's not far.
No.
Maybe-
Only half an hours.
You could come back for Thanksgiving
and we could have a, uh, are you single?
Yes.
Me too!
Awesome.
(audience laughs)
So we could have a single ladies' turkey fry.
That would be awesome.
All right, let's do it!
(audience applauds)
Single Ladies' Turkey Fry.
There you go.
(laughs) It's a movement.
The Annual Single Ladies Turkey Fry, it's on.
(bright theme music)